oh so many resumes let's see okay
Mike looks pretty good okay this is a
scene that happens every day an employer
checks you out online you may think that
your first impression will come when you
meet your employer so you practice your
firm handshake you work on your best and
most winning smile
you may even do something really crazy
like put on a suit now you see half of
all companies look at their prospective
hires online before they meet them
before they let them enter the doors of
their company so that means that all of
you were checked out online before you
got that job you wanted and in fact here
in Silicon Valley it's probably more
than just half now a third of all
companies said that last year they
rejected a potential hire because of
information they found online I knew how
risky it could be to have an online
presence so when I was finishing up my
undergraduate degree and applying for
jobs I got off all social media I went
black because I was worried about what
would happen if I was out there in the
world and people could judge me before
they met me now I was so worried about
the downsides of this online presence
that I didn't realize there could be
great upside potential
well because the strong presence can all
help you land that job it can increase
your reputation and it can help
recruiters reach out to you
so maybe you'll land that dream job
without even having to do that much work
so we want to walk through a couple
things we've found in our research so
I'll help you have a strong social media
presence the first one is to be personal
so what's unique about you be attractive
we're not talking visually only but
don't be not talking about your face I'm
talking about in your room in your
online presence in your post and
everything you do but help them see why
you joining their company would be a
benefit to them and finally be focused
have a real message about you what you
want to do and what you want to
accomplish so be personal be attractive
be focused
this will get you headed down the path
to success and that's what we want to
share with you today we want to help you
see how going down the path to success
what it looks like on LinkedIn on
Twitter and other platforms and how this
can help you succeed so now you guys
know that the first step on the path to
success is being personal and on
LinkedIn you have the opportunity to
share more about yourself you don't want
this to be just a digital version of
your resume or a recitation of your
baseball card stats instead you want to
use this opportunity to share your story
and to control the narrative about who
you are as an individual both personally
and professionally so let's take a look
here at my profile I definitely have the
attractive down but you see I've left
out the key summary section which is a
great opportunity to share a story about
yourself so I want to look to my
teammates here to see if they could
provide us with some
examples and you can see none of them
have a summary session so I instead went
to one of my other classmates a guy
named Omid you guys probably know him he
is a master of social media and so here
we can see his profile and if you scroll
down just below posts you get to his
summary and the text is too small to
read but these are five paragraphs that
give us really good insight into who
Omid is he talks about his background
who he is as a professional and also his
personal interest he mentions that he's
a photographer with over 25,000
followers on Instagram and he also goes
on to talk about his goals both
personally and professionally
so this is a great example of what to do
now the second step on the path to
success is attractive and on LinkedIn
attractiveness our attractiveness of
your profile is largely a function of
how complete it is LinkedIn data shows
that complete profiles that's profiles
that have filled out all the different
sections are 40 times more likely to
receive offers from recruiters so I
wanted to find an example of perhaps an
underdeveloped profile and found
inspiration in my lovely teammate Tina
no offence so here we can see her
professional experience isn't really
built out sparse details and education
is similarly unclear and you know
Berkeley twice Stanford three times very
impressive I have no idea what the hell
is going on
so now let's go back to our favorite guy
Oh me so we can see after this summary
section he's filled out all of the
different parts of his profile to an
appropriate extent there's not so much
text as to be overwhelming but it
provides us with a really comprehensive
view of Omid and it gives his profile
that attractiveness that we're looking
for now the last step on the path to
success is focus so in LinkedIn focus is
largely manifested through the use of
keywords these are words and phrases
that you're going to pepper throughout
your profile and they're really
important because it determines how your
profile will be treated by the LinkedIn
search algorithm so this has a huge
impact on how recruiters will be able to
find you now you might be wondering how
can I figure out what keywords are gonna
be most important to put in my profile
now I'm going to suggest one useful tool
that I found in my research so I say
that you should go to a job description
for a job that you really want the dream
job let's say it's a program manager at
Google so you can go to that website and
copy down the description then you find
a free word cloud tool online which you
can copy and paste the text into this
and it will generate this wonderful
keyword map and you can see what are the
words that are most important for the
job that you're looking for and so you
can see using this tool you can find you
can really optimize your strategy for
keywords on LinkedIn so another really
useful tool is Twitter and Twitter is
particularly great for your personal
brand because not only does it let you
establish your own credibility as an
expert in your own field of expertise
but it also allows you to engage with
their target audience and also have some
sort of unique authentic personality
while still maintaining the level of
professionalism so going back to Pat the
success the first part is P which is
personal and in the case of Twitter this
means you want to come across as a
genuine person a real person an Aaron
Levie CEO of boxes a business really
well he says that he's the the lead
magician at box which conveys his humor
he's a fun person and also talks about
he's a huge Abba fan which again talks
about how he's pretty humorous
personality and whatnot another person
who does a good exam
is Mary Barra who will be on campus in a
few weeks for commencement now she's an
expert head of GM plus a lot about
automobiles and whatnot
but she also talked about STEM education
and her passion for that and that's
unique to her now this obviously flows
into tweets as well mary has a lot of
tweets about about GM and the car
industry etc but she also has personal
touches but alluding to STEM education
again and what not
now the next step of the path to success
is a attractiveness and for Twitter this
means you want to provide the very
visually appealing content images that
draw in your your followers etc and also
content that's relevant and useful to
people that follow you a good example of
this is Marc Jacobs who is very very
well known in the fashion world and you
can see one from his profile one glance
shows you this is very engaging and very
relevant to its users at the same time
though this is especially important for
your tweets in fact pictures that are
tweets that include pictures are two
times more engaging and more interactive
than tweets that just have text on the
same note though you want to be active
on Twitter being active helps to be
found and be followed and this might
seem a little bit complicated a lot of
work and whatnot but retweeting is
actually an easy cheap just find fault
find influencers that are very relevant
to your industry and use these as a way
to really easily make content now the
last part of the path of success is F
which is focus and for Twitter this is
very simple just keep it short and sweet
now tweets are already very very short
but it's been shown that tweets that are
actually even shorter are actually more
effective and more engaging than you
know
then longer so another part of focus
though is not only short and sweet but
also focus on your field of expertise
what do you want to be known for is
there a certain energy you want to be
known for and that's a case like Aaron
Levie you want to be an expert in tech
convey that through your focus put most
of your content relevant to whatever you
want to be known for and through these
steps now you should know the path to
success very well this is a great way to
craft your twitter strategy and showcase
your personal brand
tada you guys have seen what the path of
success looks like in the professional
context but actually goes beyond that
into the personal context as the only
single person on team three my team gave
me some indirect advice and said Rajan
why don't you research more what the
path to success looks like in the online
dating world so I did my research looked
up a lot and learned a whole lot things
like if you put surfing as a hobby
you're actually more likely to get
engagement however as I thought about
this more and reflected on the most
important part of the path model P being
personal especially in this context I
realized what's most important is
actually being genuine it's just like
dating in real life what's most
important is that you or yourself and
not necessarily trying to maximize the
Norfolk connections you get but rather
getting the right quality of connection
so the advice we have for you is sure
there are tips you could do to actually
get more swipe rights but rather it's
about getting the right ones so if
you're not funny don't try and be funny
in and make jokes if you are let that
come through in your profile but this
all comes through more in just two words
even the pictures one thing you can do
is illustrate who you are by having
pictures that show your hobbies sure you
probably have this great picture of you
from a wedding that's framed really well
and you look great but take something
more natural something that shows who
you are we're all full well-rounded
people and why we may be defined by a
profession their hobbies that we have
that define us as well so show that
through your profile pictures now
speaking of pictures a attractive there
are a few things you can do and a few
things you should avoid one thing to
avoid is what we call the Where's Waldo
picture
we know you have a lot of friends and
you're popular and your friends are
good-looking too but who are you and
what am I looking for here the other
thing you can do is make sure you smile
make sure you have a high-resolution
picture something clear that you can see
especially for your default picture and
again be genuine be yourself let your
personality show something that's very
unattractive is negativity so avoid
making negative statements instead try
and reframe things in a positive light
you're much more likely to get
engagement and this one something
personally I care about one of the
biggest turn offs spelling mistakes and
bad grammar so make sure you proofread
your profile and any messages you send
to avoid that and lastly is the
importance of focus one of the reasons
focus really matters is because on your
profile you're not just trying to show
other people who you are you're also
indicating to them what you're looking
for so be very clear in what that is and
be explicit are you looking for a
hook-up are you looking for casual
dating or you're looking to find the
love of your life whatever it is you
should say that clearly and make that
focus you don't want to show up on a
date and have mixed expectations there
also instead of saying things in terms
of what you're looking for in a
characteristic try and frame it in a
values perspective
so again we hope that this perhaps the
success can can help you both in
professional and personal realms I'm
actually really happy that I get the
last word on this so I thought what we
should do is take a minute and actually
let's criticize everything that's wrong
with Erics LinkedIn I'm actually going
to take the high road on this one so
we've shown you that the importance of
having a social media profile why
because it's the first impression that
you bring to people as Andy mentioned
before people get on the call with you
what do they do they are they're either
Google you are they looking up on
LinkedIn so while some of us think that
it is an option not to have a great
social media profile that's not the case
because before you walk into the door
someone has looked you up and they have
an idea they've already preformed the
bias about what they think about you so
why don't we have better social media
profiles why don't I have a better
LinkedIn profile I don't know because
it's overwhelming
it takes time I'm not an expert I don't
know what to do
and all of these different reasons right
but we've shown you guys a framework
that have framework that will help you
get on your first step to bettering your
social media profile
so again path is personal attractive and
focused in fact I myself was so inspired
by my teammates feedback and by this
framework that I ended up updating my
own personal my LinkedIn profile so I
added a summary I added content and then
I added a bunch of my interest and
it actually thank you you're clapping
for me it actually did not take me more
than a couple of hours and what was
really surprising to me was that I
actually was in an hour I got a notice
from
LinkedIn saying that my profile ranking
has increased by 3% and I felt so much
more comfortable adding people on
LinkedIn so I think some of you receive
probably the last couple days you
received a lot of LinkedIn invitations
from me because I'm just so much more
confident in my in my profile and I know
I didn't go to Stanford three times so I
mean as well so to help you guys on your
first step to better your social profile
we put together a handout with the path
framework and you can guys I think we
have it at the end of each row so if you
don't mind passing you it down so after
this presentation take a look and make a
commitment like I did to improve at
least one area one of your social media
platforms and then you'll see the
benefits